-Our next guest is a
very funny comedian.
His international
music collective, "Temps,"
has released their debut single,
"no,no," which is available now.
Please, welcome back to the show
James Acaster, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
James, I'm so happy to have you
here in person.
-Thank you, Seth.
It's good to see you.
-You're doing a U.S. tour.
-Yeah, yeah, I'm touring the...
I'm touring the U.S.
-Got a new show called...
-U.S. of "A."
-...called -- Your new show is
called "Hecklers Welcome."
-Guess what the "A" stands for.
-The U.S. of "A"?
-Yes.
-What does the "A"
in U.S. of "A" stand for?
-America.
You should know, man.
You live here.
That's embarrassing.
That's some embarrassing stuff.
I do my research before I talk.
-So, the show is called
"Hecklers Welcome."
A lot of comedians
don't like hecklers,
but it seems like you're just
going to encourage them.
-Oh, I really don't like them.
-Okay. Oh.
-Yeah, I hate hecklers.
-Okay.
-But I wanted to get over that,
and this is like
exposure therapy.
Do you know what that is?
-Yeah, like if you're
afraid of spiders,
they put them all over you.
-Yeah, like if Macaulay Culkin
stuck his head in a beehive.
-Was that what that was?
That was exposure therapy?
-That's what that
whole film's about.
-I had no idea.
Changes it.
-Yeah, yeah, he's scared of
loads of stuff, that kid.
Burglars.
He's scared of burglars.
-Oh, did he invite
the burglars to come
as a way of getting over
his fear of burglars?
-They cut that scene from
the film where
his therapist tells him,
"Why don't you just try exposing
yourself to more burglars."
That was what
the whole thing was about.
-Wow! I feel bad for
whoever played the therapist.
Obviously, that was a pretty
juicy part, and then --
-Yeah, yeah.
That was pretty bad.
But that was -- You know who
played the therapist?
-Who was that?
-David Pumpkins.
-The "SNL" character?
-Yeah, yeah.
That was -- He got his break
further down the line
when he got on "SNL."
But it was originally
David S. Pumpkins.
-You have a musical collective
called Temps.
-Guilty.
-And you have a new song out.
And this is from
the video of the song,
and this is
an alligator suit of sorts.
And this is your alligator suit.
-Yes, I had that
made for myself,
and I'm in that alligator suit.
-Gotcha.
-And I got heatstroke.
-Really?
Do you blame it on the suit
or the day you filmed the video
or a combination?
-A combination.
Also my own stupidity.
-Okay.
-It wasn't a good idea.
I wouldn't advise it to anyone.
But I got myself an
alligator mascot suit made,
and for -- I might as well have
gotten on the roller coasters.
Actually, that was day two.
Day one, I got heatstroke.
-Well, you really -- I mean,
these seem like awful things
to be doing in an alligator suit
on a hot day.
What was your vision?
Why did you want to make
an alligator suit?
-Well, I had
a toy like that as a kid,
a massive party gator.
-Uh-huh.
-T-shirt says, "Party gator."
I won it at a fair.
-Uh-huh.
-Got it as a kid at
the same time I got my drum kit.
Then, as an adult, made this
album, got the drum kit,
got the party gator
back from my parents' house.
It was meant to be a big thing,
and then, when COVID hit,
I gave both of them, the
drum kit and the party gator,
to a school I used to work at
for safekeeping.
-Uh-huh.
-Then, for a video, I was like,
"I'm going to put that
toy in the video."
Phoned the school up.
They were like, "Yeah,
we threw that in the trash."
"Oh, that was my childhood toy."
They're like, "Yeah. Thanks."
And --
[ Laughter ]
So then I had to
get that made myself.
Obviously,
that's what I had to do.
I was like, "I guess I've become
the party gator now."
-Well, there was something --
You used to work at
the amusement park, right?
-I used to work there.
I used to serve food and drink
at that amusement park.
That's how they let me in now.
They give me
the run of the place.
-Oh, wow.
So if you work at an
amusement park in England,
you just sort of -- Forever,
the rest of your life, you're --
-You phone them up and go, "I'm
dressed as a party gator today.
Can I come in?
They're like,
"You don't even need to ask."
-They did an even nicer thing.
They named the goat at
the amusement park after you.
-Yep, that goat is called
James Acaster.
-Wow! Did you ever think,
when your career started,
it would hit that height?
-Well, I always hoped that,
one day, I'd be the GOAT.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You did it.
-I did it, man.
-You did it. Pretty early.
And now who knows
what height you're going to hit.
Already the GOAT.
-Yeah, I can't wait to see
what dizzy heights I get to.
Here we are at 30 Rock.
It means a lot, man.
This is where I first heard of
David S. Pumpkins.
-Right, at 30 Rock.
-30 Rock. And now I'm here.
-And then --
You first heard of him here,
then you IMDB'd him, saw that he
was cut from "Home Alone."
-I was like, "Oh, I bet there's
an interesting story
behind that."
-You also -- So, you're a
music producer, a stand-up,
You have a true-crime podcast.
-Yeah, I've got the
true-crime podcast coming out.
What a lot people
don't know about me is that --
Yeah, you know me as
a stand-up comedian.
-I do.
-But I'm actually
an undercover cop
who's undercover
as a stand-up comedian.
-Oh. From the beginning?
-From the very beginning.
I had to infiltrate
a gang of drug dealers
who were dealing drugs
to comedians
backstage at comedy gigs.
So I became a stand-up comedian
to infiltrate the gang.
The case didn't go great,
but my comedy career has gone
from strength to strength.
-Oh.
-That's just what happened.
And I've decided, now that I've
been kicked out the force,
I'll just do
a true-crime podcast
where I share my wire recordings
with the public.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. So that's what it is.
It's called "Springleaf."
We've got
a Kickstarter for it now,
because I ain't paying for it.
-Why should you?
-Why should I pay for it?
I'm on an undercover cop.
You see the wages we're on?
-Is it better or worse wages
when you go undercover?
Do you get a per diem
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get a per diem.
They go like,
"You're being undercover today,
so you have this."
And what I --
The mistake I make is that I --
In front of the drug dealers,
I pull out my per diems
in the envelope that says
"Undercover-cop per diems."
"Now, what's that?"
I'm like, "Oh, just a joke."
-Oh, well, that's a good cover.
-Comedian -- they love it.
-You also have a self-help book.
-Yeah.
-Based on something
you went through?
-What people don't know
about me, Seth --
-Uh-huh. Is most of it.
-Yeah, I'm a party gator.
I'm a musician.
I'm a comedian.
I'm an undercover cop.
I'm also a self-help guru.
-Okay.
-I came off of social media.
Everyone wanted to know
how I did it.
So I've released
"James Acaster's
Guide to Quitting Social Media:
Being the Best You You Can Be
and Curing Yourself
of Loneliness -- Volume 1."
-Okay.
-A lot of tips in there
about how to quit social media.
The main important thing is,
you have to take what
social media used to
give you and you have to
replicate that
in your day-to-day life.
-Oh, interesting.
-So, now, you know,
in normal life,
I have to stalk my girlfriends
for real -- my ex-girlfriends.
I start arguments
with strangers all the time.
-Just on the street?
-Really aggressive arguments.
Saying stuff that I should not
be saying, quite frankly.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I do all of that,
and if you want to get
updates on
all your friends' kids,
you got to do what I did
and open your own crèche.
Do you even call it
a crèche in this country?
I got the big sense just then
that you don't.
Listen, when I did
my research about America,
I learned what the "A" stood for
and I stopped there.
I didn't bother looking up
if you had crèches or not.
-There was a real -- You felt
the wind when you said "crèche."
-Oh, I felt it. I felt it hard.
-What do you think -- I feel bad
that I haven't even --
Based on what you said, I still
don't know what a crèche is.
How would you describe it?
I'll try to find
the word for it.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's like where people go
and drop their kids off
for the day to be looked after.
-Like a daycare.
-Yeah, if you want to say that.
-Well, now you know.
You're going to do
your show here in New York City.
You're doing stand-up here.
-Yeah, I'm doing stand-up here
in New York City.
I'm going to yell out,
"Hey, give me a cheer
if you came from the crèche!
Oh, no [bleep]
Daycare! Daycare!"
-And then think of me
and how I bailed you out.
-Yeah, I'll be like, "That joke
goes out to Seth Meyers."
Actually, I'm gonna dedicate
every joke tonight to you, Seth.
And I won't even
tell the audience why,
but I will say it
after every single gag.
-I have really enjoyed
having you here.
Thank you so much
for making time.
Please come back soon.
Have a great tour.
-It's been a pleasure, Seth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-James Acaster, everybody.
"no,no" is out now.
We'll be right back.